è la benetton i ragazzi femmine sono
video dove si carcerato però è lottato
sul comodino stamane mi sembra molto
[ __ ] sembrano molto fashion siamo
ragazzi su una serie di videogiochi che
stanno uscendo si chiama horror cei cioè
fiamme horror questo è una fiaba horror
però non so come si chiama perché nel
menù non hanno messo il nome va bene
stanno facendo diverse questa è la prima
scusate se ho poca voce però è da poco
che ho fatto la 24ore ancora hanno
recuperato la voce l'al alhy video di
oltre facciamo play visto che credo che
sia un gioco fatto proprio bene perché
ho visto un paio di senso adesso che
superfigo si no ma top del mav è
incredibile vabbè chiesto e cos'è sta
roba miglia non ha mai visto un horror
partire così bene ragazzi torna a casa
non puoi tornare a casa ora trova una
bottiglia di vino rosso
bellissimo ma certo è pressata mente
quello che farei in un protone ecco la
bottiglia
l'ho trovata subito oggi ne andiamo
ci sono un sacco di bottiglie rotte e
bellissimo è bellissimo è fatto troppo
bene ma se siamo passati
dalla tua sorella
[Musica]
che cazzo se ami suite game salve c'è ma
perché questo spara debole ecco perché
le bottiglie sono note spara le
bottiglie cioè non ho capito ma
seriamente a si è chiuso qua la porta è
chiusa beh ma ci mancherebbe altro non
ci vuole andare con le spara le botte
sto schizzato maledetto che devo andare
di qua no mi sembra strano che abbia
siamo passati dall ambientazione stavo
dicendo lamentazioni incredibile a
tetro inserirlo due secondi e bellissimo
tra l'altro la dovrete è arrivato lo zio
sarà qua
e arriva passo io di qua che comunque e
c è giorno quindi mail giorno è meglio
passa di certo parcheggiamo le quali
barche non vedo perché no
l'ep crouch andiamo esattamente dalla
parte opposta di quel tizio questa mi
piace
questa brinda ma non sono che pesca le
bottiglie va bene e porta dal re
salve ma e non era 18 lo zio ma scusami
adesso è uscito di qua c'è bisogno della
chiara proprio ma guarda meglio che non
l'apriamo sto punto ma che cacchio è sto
gioco incredibile c'è un tizio che va in
giro a caso spara le bottiglie sé ma zio
sam andare al poligono va il poligono
c'è ma non ho capito il ma scusa sembra
un po l'ambientazione di giorno di
little nightmares però sono interni in
prima persona la cosa in sé sono altro
soprattutto hanno trovato una chiave di
saragat porca [ __ ] ok
credo che la chiave serve ad aprire la
porta e cioè a sinistra e premendo a
sinistra e
si è chiusa la serranda io non vorrei
che oggi lo zio
ma dov'è che va
no non chiudi che scherzavo vabbè se ne
fa niente mi riguarda se aperta la porta
nel punto sbagliato da tavole vandali
per adesso ragazzi tutto bene cos'è qua
o sfondando tutto fratelli è che
non ho franca perché mi ascolta questa
roba tutto fa un tuffo nel vuoto no
posso fare climbing che servito qua o
barricato la foto forse dovevo farlo con
la porta aperta altro punto non così a
cazzo frena e gas al dirupo
ok forse la prima porta ok a prima porta
e poi fare sta cosa va bene c'è un topo
grosso come mio zio
gravità enorme un chihuahua sto troppo
bene
che non sono sicurissimo mannaggia a
sissi amica c'è proprio la la scogliera
bellissimo rischio di annegare al 2000
per cento però fa niente
non mi fidavo della trave lato pubblico
così sarò jobs jobs che
dopo che non c'è un jobs che il pazzesco
ragazzi non li leggo più i giochi horror
come una volta 90 relica lillo gioco
subito capito subiti jones centrare
bastard touch velluto fax
dunque
dov'è che sarà andar domandato ma scusa
ma c'è un tizio che gira di qua e io mi
devo trovare a fare a cazzotti con i
topi
minga non mi farebbe miei l'aria
maronati spacco la faccia aspetta che
non ho più voce che non sono molto
credibile
ma ora che le hanno paura coste di cosma
sono dati pare
che verranno poi come se va beh
perché cacchio di posto è questo
va bè ragazzi siamo un po esagerato tiro
ho aperto qualcosa ma non so cosa non ci
tengo ad andare quadro di ciò che
provvediamo
almeno solo per vedere cosa c'è
spero non ci siano tizi brutti che
vogliono uccidermi per quello sicuro
comunque
bel salto
dove cazzo dove sto andando per un'ora
di giro dove cos'è
cos'è cos'è quale
c'è una bolla ok
porca put a
ok dove che siamo
sto capendo niente va beh gli enigmi
pure già non solo fare i tre più due
questo era fin qua però gli altri non li
so ci potrebbe essere qualsiasi cosa
questo non ho idea
brown ha un bel salani eccolo one possa
buttare tua madre morta ieri coi topi
quanto di più la mano è
un vicolo cieco ma cos'è ma qualche
gioco è ma cos'è ma cosa c'era uno senza
la testa io veramente non so neanche
cosa non so manco cosa dire cos'è ecco
cosa così e con la canzone perché non
c'è una donna che brutta
ma non è che per caso hai bevuto un
pennino pure tu potrebbe essere magari
se un po ubriaco intese accorto va bene
c'è un mare di vino che non ho capito il
motivo ma pullback c'è si vede che lo
capirà più avanti bella la trama sopra
sono anche meno grip
e tizi senza testa che provano ucciderti
avere tutto l'arma ragazzi fino adesso
non vedo niente di strano ok perfetto
no no è successo e succede tutto e non
so se è ok
eccoli qua alla bottiglia con un
bicchiere
cavatappi con foglia c'è scritto questo
quindi immagino che sia quello
ma
fa come come
o
cosa non o meno sto capendo nokia ma
tattico la foglia ok questo non mi
ricordo cosa pensa di questo qua
let's go my brothers che genio proprio
lui proprio lui la trova la castiga
bellissimo comunque c'era un mare di
mino tutto vociare allegro quindi il
mondo allegroni prima è scomparso siamo
in un mare di vino tutto allegro tutto
bellissimo
beh pro bello ragazzi finora mista piace
ha una vita
che è successo siamo calmi ci mettiamo
questi di là che fanno peso
ok se diciamo anche a mettere il topo
che fa ancora più peso meglio
garantite stronzi allarma scusa 3 in
software sia mamma mia anzi assassin's
creed per i più giovani tutti i
giovincelli ci abbiamo messo al 62 anni
ma tutto a posto
prevedo
sta facendo prevedo un jump square di
quelli belli pesanti meno male meno male
che hanno detto prima james che vi è
sfruttato prima che che lo dicessi
che qui si è rotta la maniglia che
succedono capisco
cioè si è rotta la maniglia biso girato
il cielo un muro bomber non capire a
quali modo erano prima
google è stato prevedibile su alcuni
jump si calma comunque imprevedibile
sicuro che succede dopo tutto ciò che
strano mi piace prendere gems che a
ragazzi è una roba mi sono proprio
allegro ogni tanto lo faccio proprio per
divertirmi che evita di merda aspettavo
che mi spacco la mv ha dato tanto e lui
mi riferisco alla legge sull altra parte
a due ore e mezza per raggiungere
l'altra parte quella 9 capito dove
stiamo andando effettivamente sta roba
serve per fare da ponte
qualcosa si spacca questo nostro ne
dubito emiliano del cazzo
non finisce solo benissimo
vai a sfondare tutto fratelli non hai
capito bene dove stai andando perché c'è
un muro i fermi
bene ha spiegato è servito schema
perfetto
alla contare da subito saltare prima che
questo che occorre un metro e poi
stankovic è proprio il massimo
siamo ei
aspetto
è come prenderla m ragazzi di strada vi
faccio sempre così
fantastico
all e tu internet ma ce l'abbiamo il
vino almeno tutto questo ma perché una
billinton minchia sto male il labirinto
purtroppo ragazzi cioè non so se riesco
è un po troppo per la pelle mio cell
vabbè ci sono i topi grossi come mio zio
veramente ovunque ma basta anche alla
merito ciao ragazzi fatevi una vita che
palle da piccolo e leggero geronimo
stilton mi sono chiari di vedere topi in
giro che a posto si può andare i 46
nella v non si capisce di qua ci
dovrebbe essere la porta quella che
stava prima qua no non so orientarmi
sono giustificate ci hanno avverito
nelle email e nei paraggi dovrebbe
esserci quella porta che c'era prima che
non riuscivo ad aprire che forse adesso
resterà aprile vediamo dead set mamma
mia è tutto qua
ah sì stronzo ma scusa non si aprirà non
si aprì qua questo si apre a così breve
si è aperta una carica che casa già un
labirinto fuori c'è la scusa di qualche
giro c'è in giro pazzesco fatto ragazzi
avrei comunque importante che tutto sia
sbloccato esci ghezzi ok benissimo cioè
guarda per arrivare fin qua veramente
sommesso 62 anni 9 x
type e
cioè che schifo ti chiamerò paoluccio
c'è veramente bruttissimo come si fa è
sì un po eccessivo
poi ci si ma ed evo devo trovare tutti
quelli non me li ricordo più zio minchia
sull vent'anni questo poi per questo
c'erano per la caraffa c'era la
bottiglia
per il bicchiere c'era no questa sera la
sacca porsche raga non mi ricordo più
gaza il passato due ore sono passate ma
come le prove con due solo questa che mi
mancava che proprio diversa
vorrei provarle tutte a posto la posta
posta a posto a posto anche con le
verifiche facciamo così infatti sono
uscito da scuola per miracolo però vabbè
è
bello allegro vado
bene i ragazzi questo era il primo
episodio di è come cassino forse col
vino meravigli se voi siete ragazzi sarà
un altro episodio altri due episodi
scorso perché è incredibile
chi scrive ha lasciato momento è un mi
piace e noi come sempre agazzi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo vi è la ragazzi
[Musica]